Let's talk about it. So, what's
happening? Talk to me about your
challenge with Trinity. What is it that
you seen in scripture that made you
doubt?
Okay.
So, everything that Jesus said while he
was here in his teachings and his
miracles that it was his father's will.
You know, he said I could do nothing on
my own
without the Father.
>> John 5:19. Can you tell me what the
context of John 5:19 is? Cuz I know what
you're referring to.
>> John 5:19? Yeah, that's it. Don't look
it up because you're saying the Son
cannot do a single thing on his own
initiative. Mhm.
>> know what the context is there?
No.
Exactly.
Cuz what you did was, I'm just telling
you as a as a father, cuz I'm old enough
to be your dad.
Mhm.
What you did was you heard someone quote
a verse out of context, John 5:19 or
John 5:30 or John 14:28, "The Father is
greater than I."
And you didn't bother to go read the
context to see that Jesus is teaching
the opposite point of what you think.
Cuz what was the Father's will?
The Father's will was for the Son to
become flesh, speak the words of the
Father, and do the Father's deeds. But
in that, what the Father sent the Son to
do is to confirm that he's God.
That's actually the context of John 5,
but you didn't read it. But I'm going to
read it for you. Okay.
So, yeah, I know where you're coming
from. I've been through that. I because
Jehovah's Witnesses,
Muslims, Unitarians have used the same
passages over and over again.
So, I'm going to walk you through this.
Okay.
>> what happens when you listen to kids on
TikTok, but thank Jesus cuz
seeking God with all your heart, and if
your motives are pure, he's going to
bring you the truth and the right
teachers. And in spite of my sins, I
pray I'm one of them to show you what
the Bible says. Now, here's the passage
that you had in mind. You may not know
you had this in mind, but I'm going to
show you, but I'm just going to read the
first part.
For therefore, Jesus answered and was
saying to them, "Truly, truly say I say
to you, the Son can do nothing from
himself
unless it is something he sees the
Father doing." Now, that's one.
The other one you have in mind is John
6:38.
Okay. Now, if I just stop there,
John 5, "I've come down from heaven not
to do my own will, but the will of him
who sent me." All right.
Now, if I just read this part, we're
just going to look at that part.
We're not going to read anything else.
Just stop here.
"Truly, truly I say to you, the Son can
do nothing from himself." It sounds like
he's denying he's God, right? If I stop
there? Yes.
Okay. Now, I'm going to ask you a
question when I finish the verse.
"Unless it is something he sees the
Father doing. For whatever the Father
does,
these things the Son also does in the
same manner." Now, I finished the verse.
Wait till I finish all of it.
I'm going to ask you a question.
You
Do you only do what God does, and you do
whatever God does the way God does it?
No.
Can any mere creature say, "I only do
what God does, and whatever God does, I
do it the way he does it"? No.
So, why didn't you finish the verse to
show you that Jesus taught the opposite
point? That he is not some renegade
independent deity in competition with
the Father.
He is the Son who's inseparable from
Father, and does whatever the Father
does in the same way the Father does it.
Does that sound like a creature
speaking? No, not at all.
So, what happens when you don't read
context?
Mhm.
I see.
>> let's continue reading though just to
prove my point.
"For the Father loves the Son and shows
him all things that he himself is doing.
And the Father will show him greater
works than these so that you may marvel.
For just as the Father raises the dead
and gives them life, even so the Son
also gives life to whom he wishes." That
sounds like he's denying that he's God?
No.
So, he's telling you, "Whatever he does,
I do, and when he acts, I act cuz we act
in inseparably."
He does, I do. We do it together
simultaneously. So, when he raised the
dead, I'm raising the dead cuz we work
together. So, can you show me and ask
the Muslims to show you or the Jehovah's
Witnesses to show you a single verse
in the Quran
or in the Old Testament where a
creature, whether angelic creature
or prophet says, "Whatever God does, I
do the same way he does it, and just
like he raised the dead and gives life,
I give life to whom I want"?
Does that sound like Jesus denying he's
God?
No, it doesn't. All right. Let's
continue.
And you give me all their objections.
Okay. Yeah. "For [snorts] just as the
Father raises the dead before Let me
finish this stuff first."
>> Okay. Okay. Okay. "Father raises the
dead and gives them life, even so the
Son also gives life to whom he wishes.
For not even the Father judges anyone,
but he has given all judgment to the
Son." For what reason? "So that all will
honor the Son even as they honor the
Father." So, I'm going to ask you
another question.
Can any creature say, "You must give me
the same honor that you give God
Almighty"?
No.
Now, explain to me how did Jesus say
that if he's not equal to the Father in
essence?
"So that all will honor the Son even as
they honor the Father."
So, the Father wants you to give his Son
the same honor you give to the Father.
So, what you learn is he's not the
Father. That's why I'm a Trinitarian.
But he's equal to the Father in that
whatever the Father does, he can do
because he has the same power and nature
the Father has,
but he's also man, something the Father
is not. He also became man.
"He who does not honor the Son does not
honor the Father who sent him." Now,
since you ordered the Quran to your
mistake, when you get it, use it as
toilet paper or burn it.
Okay.
Now, be honest with you, it's garbage.
It's it's But I'm not just saying it's
satanic.
It's garbage, it's satanic, it's evil.
But I'm going to use the Quran to prove
to you that Jesus, even according to the
Quran,
Jesus was claiming to be God. You ready
for me to show you that?
I think I know where you're going, Sam,
because I watch you all the time. So,
it's like I'm
You're talking about the day of judgment
where Jesus where Jesus is actually like
the judge.
No, no, no, no. Not the judge, no. What
he does, which only God can do. So,
[snorts] if you've been watching me, how
do you still have your doubts? But let's
assuage I explore I explore too much.
No, that's okay. Exploring's one thing,
but never settling on the truth when
it's presented for you is another thing
cuz there's a warning in scripture,
"Those who always
are always learning, but never coming to
a knowledge of truth."
There's a scripture warns about that.
And gathering teachers to tickle their
ears.
Got to be careful. But here, I'm going
to I'm going to show you what I mean.
But I want to first show you the Quran,
and you're going to see Let me do this.
Let me go backwards. Oops. Sorry.
Sorry about that.
Uh sometimes these pages don't come up.
La la la la la la la la. I don't know
what the hell happened here. I put
Quran. Why is it giving me gambling?
What is gambling, man?
What is a gambling thing doing on my
thing?
Oh, it's that's because it's been
removed, right?
How's that possible?
No, that ain't impossible.
That's what I thought, dude. Shoot. Hey,
man, who's been gambling on my I don't
gamble, guys, by the way.
All right. So, don't say, "Hey, Sam, we
caught you." Caught me doing what,
sucker?
All right. Now,
this is the Quran. Look what it says
about God. Even though the the God of
the Quran is not the same God. It's a
false god.
Okay. I'm going to show you. Now, I'll
explain to you why.
That is because God, he is the truth. I
notice the Quran says, "God is the
truth." Remember this name, truth. Yeah.
>> God is the truth.
"And brings the dead to life, and is
powerful over everything.
Because the hour is coming, no doubt of
it, God shall raise up whosoever is
within the tombs." So, Quran is quite
clear. That hour, it is God, or in
Arabic, Allah, who will resurrect the
dead.
Yes. Physically resurrect them at that
hour and gives life to the dead, right?
Yes. And he is the truth, right? Now,
you ask a Muslim, "Show me in the Quran
Show me in the Quran anyone besides your
God saying he is the truth." They can't
show you that.
Now, Quran comes about 600 years after
Jesus Christ our Lord.
So, the Gospel of John is long before
the Quran.
I'm going to show you that Muhammad
takes the words of Christ, plagiarizes
the words, changes them, and ascribes
them to Allah. But in doing that, he
proves that Jesus must have claimed to
be God cuz I want you to see this. Allah
is the truth. He gives life to the dead.
The hour is coming. Allah will raise
them from their tombs. All right.
Let's see what Jesus claimed.
John 5:25.
"Truly, truly I say to you, an hour is
coming." Sound familiar? "An hour is
coming, and now is, when the dead will
hear the voice of the Son of God, and
those who hear will live." Who's going
to raise the dead
at that hour?
The Son of God.
But according to Quran, that's something
only God does.
Right.
All right.
Did you remember that here? In case you
missed it,
I'm going to show you again.
"The hour is coming,
no doubt of it, God shall raise up
whosoever is within the tombs."
And what does God also do?
Gives life to the dead,
and he's the truth. Well, let's see what
Jesus says.
Jesus says, "The dead will hear the
voice of the Son of God." Now, who does
he think he is that by the power of his
voice, he can make
countless numbers of people alive? Does
that sound like a mere creature to you?
>> No, that sounds like God. All right.
Well, let's But notice, he's not the
Father though.
That's why we're Trinitarians.
But let's jump to 28:29.
"Do not marvel at this, for an hour is
coming." There's that language again.
"In which all who are in the tombs will
hear his voice." In case you missed it,
whose voice? Same chapter.
Whose voice are they going to hear? The
Son of God.
"And when they hear his voice, those who
are physically dead will come out, will
come forth.
Those who did good the good deeds to
resurrection life,
those who commit evil deeds to
resurrection of judgment. And in case
you missed it, John 14:6, Jesus said to
him, "I am the way
and the truth and the life." So, here's
my challenge to you and to those
TikTokers. Mhm. Show me a single verse
in the Quran where someone other than
God says he's the truth and the life.
And if you're a Jehovah Witness, show me
someone besides Jehovah in the Old
Testament says he's the truth and the
life.
Jesus says, "I'm the truth and the life.
No one comes to the Father but through
me." But wait, if he's the truth, he's
the life,
and his voice will raise the dead
physically out of their graves at the
tombs at that hour, but then the Quran
tells me that is what God does.
God is the truth,
brings the dead to life.
>> [snorts]
>> The hour's coming, God will raise them
from their tombs. You're still telling
me Jesus didn't claim to be God?
You sure You serious?
Now, I'll look at it from this
perspective with more knowledge and
insight.
Now, I'm starting to, you know, think
he's God now from what I just read. Oh,
let's throw all the objections here
because every objection you show me, I'm
going to show you from the same book,
same chapter, same author that he's the
God man cuz don't forget, he's not just
God.
He's man.
God became man and ceased being God and
at the same time, he's not the Father,
not the Spirit. That's why we had to
come up with a doctrine to make sense of
what the Bible says.
So, what's the second objection?
Okay. Um
I'm looking through the Gospels right
now to see, but it was when it was after
his um after his resurrection. He
appeared to his disciples and it said
God stopped them from seeing him.
That God stopped them from seeing him.
Yes, after his resurrection.
I don't [snorts] want to laugh because
that's doesn't exist in the Gospels.
Um it's in my um it's it's in my NLT
Bible. That I guess it
>> that's because it's a paraphrase, but
are you referring to Luke where they
were prevented from recognizing him?
Yes. Yeah, Luke, that's a paraphrase. It
says they were prevented. What does that
got to do with Jesus's divinity?
Uh because 24, right? Yeah. Yeah. And
the NLT paraphrases the word God is not
in the text. But what's what's the
objection though? I don't I don't
follow. Oh, because it said that God
stopped them from seeing Jesus like in
names like two separate people. It named
God and Jesus differently. That's why I
it grew Brother, this is why you're
killing me. So, if
the Father's called God,
Mhm.
but Jesus is then
not called God in that context to
differentiate him from God,
you're telling me then that means Jesus
isn't God also? Because I'm going to
give you something similar to show you
your logic is faulty even with human
analogy.
George Foreman had seven sons, right?
Yes.
They're all called George.
They're all George Foreman. So, if I
follow your logic,
if
someone is called George Foreman,
that means if he has a son called George
Foreman, well, it can't be
because you have someone else with that
name, so you can't have a second person
with that name. See, this is the kind of
argument you're using in telling me just
because in a text the Father's called
God to differentiate him from the Son,
that means somehow the Son is not God.
Now, let me give you a biblical example
to show you your logic doesn't follow.
All right. Okay. Now, who was Eve's
husband?
Adam.
What was Eve's name?
Eve's name? Yeah.
Uh she was called man, correct? She was
called Adam. Oh, yeah, Adam. Sorry.
But then
she's the wife of Adam, right?
Right. So, if I show you Genesis 4:1, it
says Adam knew his wife.
Because she's there not called Adam,
that means she can't be Adam?
Even though we're told right here in
Genesis 5:2,
he created them male and female, blessed
them, and called their name Adam on the
day that they were created. So, we're
told her name is Adam, too.
But if I follow your logic, when in
Genesis 4:
25, I'm told Adam knew his wife, see,
that means Adam cannot be the name of
Eve cuz here she's separated from Adam.
So, your logic doesn't work.
Explain how your logic works here.
And Adam knew his wife again, she bore a
son, she called him Seth. So, she's not
Adam here, right?
Right.
And Adam got her pregnant, right? Right.
But here I'm told she's also named Adam.
So, you just created a contradiction cuz
you don't understand the Bible how it
works.
Wow.
So, now explain this because you created
a contradiction.
Cuz in one place, Adam slept with Eve
and got her pregnant. So, we're so we're
we're seeing she's not Adam there,
but here we're told they're both Adam,
but according to your logic, can't be
cuz over here she's separated from Adam.
I have no explanation for that.
That's what happens when you put the
Bible in the wrong hands of someone not
trained.
Cuz you're not trained, you don't know,
you don't have a teacher to teach you.
This is why you're lost. Cuz you're
doing your own Bible study and you're
coming to your own understanding, and
then on top of it you're going to TikTok
to confuse you and you wonder why you're
confused.
All right.
So, now
can Eve
be the wife of Adam and distinguished
from Adam
while also being Adam at the same time?
Yes.
So, why can't God be distinguished from
Jesus cuz there God is his Father and
his Father is God, while in other places
Jesus also be described as God. Why does
it have to be either or? Why can't it be
both?
Explain it to me.
I can't explain that. In other words,
the answer is who told you can't be
both?
Yeah. You can have a place where God
referred to someone distinct from
Christ, his Father, cuz he's God,
without this implying that Jesus isn't
God.
Cuz when I read the Bible in its
entirety, there are places where God
refers to the Father, but there places
where Jesus is also God without being
the Father.
Eve is also Adam, yet she's married to
Adam, so in certain places she can be
distinguished from Adam without this
denying she's also Adam.
Cuz Adam refers to the nature that the
male and person have in common.
So, she can be married to an Adam
and she can be Adam in nature without
being the same person
that she's married to who's also Adam.